hi my name's Daisy and Jones hello I'm
Paula mescal and we're going to be
reading first tweets about Connell and
Marianne from our show normal people
Connell and Marianne have had more sex
than I did in my twenties and I'm only
on Episode four I've had more
relationships now on screen than in my
actual life you're blushing
you've lost a lot at the mention of
seconds I just go read Marianne saying
she would take Connell as dick pic to
her grave is my favorite part of the
whole series I've seen where it's me
being like if your dick that's Marianne
in Kona when they're like happy said
that like guys are funny I remember we
were gonna maybe do you're gonna maybe
leave out so she asks for one back and I
was like now I think Mary and that's one
because we're doing 50/50 you know
they're equal you know Mary Ann
comfortable kana lizard ask is like I
don't know if you wanna take a picture
of you you sound pretty Irish they're
like the sexiest bits of normal people
are when Connell apologizes to Mary Ann
for hurting her and then he seeks
support from a mental health
professional
I wouldn't say sexist I'd say there's a
satisfaction in seeing carnal apologize
and there's a soundtrack to being a
young man talking about is oh my oh yeah
it's interesting when you like you watch
someone feel that way like you that is
you've very you feel very close to that
person even though you have met them
like I felt very close to you took on or
watching that scene because I'm so
related to what he felt and and
obviously your performances are mouthing
that sex is good but have you ever tried
just watching Marianne and garland
instead I'm not sure what to say move
swiftly onward
not hide and seek by Imogen Heap play
during north montage sequence where a
calamari I'm getting it on while acting
like strangers in school I'm confused by
the syntax in that tweet say I knew
because I didn't realize that that
Imogen Heap song was also also the bit
where it goes like much is saying yeah
so I like absent watching it I then
obviously listen to the playlist in the
psyche is a pitiful and pinky and then I
listen to that song the whole way
through and I was like oh my gosh that's
what she say from the SNL clip have you
seen the SNL clip where I do like that
montage bit and absolutely yeah that's
really useful like the song is so
perfect for it like that was like that
song was in my head for a long time
after watching the episode okay I'd be
lying if I said the 10 minute long site
seems a normal people didn't make me
horny
but when Marian asked on earth he likes
another girl more than her and he pushes
her hair away from her face I got
attacked well that's nice further record
news oh this isn't good for your blood
pressure what they're saying is it's
like the moments of kindness or what
they find no sexy more than the sexy
bits maybe they need ymax emotion name
cuddle ensuring consent every step of
the way and then calling my own prissy
when they have sex the first time that
is so sexy so sexy
isn't it lovely people seem to forgive
Connor very quickly they do also forget
that he asked them to keep it private
yeah we'll just move swiftly past that
exhibit where he talks about concerned
it's so like is a conversation that they
have because I don't like I've never
seen like it's very rare that you see in
seems like that where that even is
something they talk about that and that
protection is like I'm very proud of
that series I agree
okay I'm loving normal people but when
Marianne and Colonel are not in the same
scenes together I don't like it I love
them together I ignore people
nice I mean I think yeah I think by the
end of filming because we brought
together so much like whenever we were
in a scene together we were like we
don't like do anything we just say the
line do you know because we kind of got
so used to like working together when
Mary Ann says carrying me over to your
bed on skype and watches and fall asleep
sideways I am starving I wholeheartedly
it's so cute
imagine me did that seem but a van Skype
they used house party and like they're
in the middle of it like Juwanna pops on
and she's like Lorraine comes on and
she's like oh no but I remember looking
at that what I saw that before the first
time I remember turning I was watching
who I was like Marianne isn't human she
is an angel she is superior the sex
scenes are normal people are very hot
but Columbine are in the book of Franco
hard homes is what personally gets me
like that is say like Marion in Carnival
you know her favorite gift is like the
Capone the hardest part of normal people
is not the sex but the moment in Italy
were and connell grabs America and
around the voice to stop for launching
herself a thoughtful Jamie the cannot
explain why it is so huh you were just
have to trust me that in a sexy show
that moment is the sexiest I was so
funny to film though because like like
we love fian so much like like he's born
and far like best friends he played
Jamie like fiona is just so annoyingly
wonderful like where's the creep you're
like I know it's nice to see Marianne
money because she's so kind of composure
you see my hands like you like all over
this kind of didn't think Connor Marion
could be any more attractive and then in
episode of eight comes along and they're
in Italy boss Franzese and well flames
flames flames what you see embarrassing
like makers that we have together should
be time on the slide for like it mount
with like they're being like okay turn
around now wrote a cigarette and people
think that's sexy well I love them to
see the photographs of the like wife
g-strings we were all
you're like because obviously we got the
tan and then we'd wash it off in the
evening in the next day we'd look a bit
more natural but at first you genuinely
like a body like a bodybuilder you were
like sparkling it was like problematic
but the town it just washed it away you
know that means you know when you turn
from the washing line but it's such a
great like it's an iconic Mariano video
and I've also whispering from a great
it's like they're whispering to each
other if you ever watch that episode
back you just acknowledge how quite
Karla Mariano that's almost fight to new
york was cancelled due to coronavirus
travel restrictions news currently fo5
losing with Mariana and currently and
don't try to tell me otherwise I mean
the novelist says in a time that
coronavirus doesn't exist so
unfortunately you're wrong I think
Marian's living with Lorraine [ __ ]
for a living do intellect she doesn't
believe in the Catalan system first of
all that character he has does not need
two people cleaning it all the time it's
not that big
Lorraine's done a lot of cleaning for
Mariano Diez maybe Marian wants to
Quinta Lorraine
I think she's she's just settled isn't
she she's finishing her degree she's
smashing it there's a statistic
challenged if Connor went to New York he
could have got coronavirus if he got it
they would be sulphide they'd be skyping
all the time to each other
that's the thing they get they very baby
house partying I have almost finished
normal people and I think I'm more
invested in Mariana and Collins
relationship that I have ever been
anything and realized that's a lovely
also I'd recommend not doing that I
think always focus on yourself rather
than fictional character
[Music]